nouveau gros plan sur un canton ce soir
nous partons eric sicaud dans le nord de
la côte d'or oui direction le canton de
montbard où la ville centre montbard a
basculé de gauche à droite l'an dernier
la nouvelle maire compte bien doubler la
mise dans ce territoire qui englobe
aussi l'ancien canton de venarey les
laumes jusqu alors détenue par la gauche
mais comme souvent cette année
le front national est en embuscade dans
cette circonscription électorale très
rural reportage elle a besoin et olivier
lopez la bataille d'alésia une page
d'histoire qui se réserve encore le
droit d'écrire un nouveau chapitre
le décor est déjà planté ce sera cette
fois celui d'un bastion de gauche
assiégé par la droite
laurence porte et marc frot représentent
la majorité départementale
l'an dernier cette dernière avait fait
tomber la ville de montbard à droite
elle rêve maintenant de conquérir le
canton cette victoire aux municipales
dès le premier tour à 55% victoire
vraiment historique
ça augure évidemment d'une dynamique ça
montre aussi que les gens ce qu'ils
veulent c'est des personnalités dans
lesquelles ils s'identifient en lesquels
ils portent beaucoup d'espoir
nous sommes vraiment un canton rural
avec deux pôles urbains importants bien
sûr mon bar la vie le centre la ville
chef lieu
et puis vénarey et on a là deux villes
qui sont force motrice et nous voulons
vraiment qu'il y ait un véritable trait
d'union entre ces deux entités la
défense de la ruralité c'est aussi le
credo de la gauche bien décidé à
défendre ses positions dans ce nouveau
canton plus grands patrick molinoz et
conseiller général sortant avec marion
mon goichon le candidat prg veut
s'appuyer sur son bilan
on a démontré sur le territoire un
attachement fort au développement de la
ruralité avec des avec des réalités
concrètes pas simplement de la
communication mais
beaucoup de projets développés en
direction de l'enfance de la petite
enfance des seniors un combat mené pas
simple pour les hôpitaux et il y à un
seul et unique adversaire l'abstention
est un ennemi mais l'abstention ces
personnes n'est c'est tout le monde
l'abstention c'est malheureusement le
désintérêt parfois de nos concitoyens
pour pour la politique mais un
désintérêt qui est beaucoup moins
important je crois pour les élus de
proximité qui développe des projets
concrets mais la tâche sera difficile le
contexte national est peu favorable à la
gauche est ici elle part divisée nous
nous disons oui ouf nous mettrons en
place une politique de gauche et le plus
loin possible que nous pourrons aller on
fera tout pour que dans le département
on puisse avoir quelque chose qui puisse
apporter au niveau de l'emploi au niveau
des services publics notamment
ça c'est important pour nous l'un des
problèmes du canton un taux de chômage
important 15 % de demandeurs d'emploi
pour le fn il est urgent d'agir voit
s'arrêter chez quelques commerçants
couteau nous sommes les arbitres de
l'élection nos adversaires le savent
pertinemment nos adversaires qui sont
adversaires qui se présentent sous des
étiquettes plus ou moins tronquée forces
du progrès majorité départementale
nous sommes les seuls à nous assumer
espérance bleu marine rassemblement bleu
marine front national parce que nous en
sommes fiers et nous pensons que nous
serons les arbitres ces élections est
mieux qu'au deuxième tour contre la
division de nos adversaires nous pouvons
l'emporter dans ce canton près de 15000
personnes sont appelées aux urnes les 22
et 29 mars prochains
et dans ce canton à noter la présence
d'un dernier binôme composé de karim
pétri divers droite et de stéphane
pennac du modem on l'a dit tout à
l'heure c'était donc aujourd'hui le
premier jour de campagne pour s'en
convaincre il suffisait de regarder
twitter absolument les comptes twitter
de toutes les institutions en profite
pour appeler au civisme à l'image de la
préfecture de saône et loire qui reprend
à son compte la campagne oui je vote
un vote dans des nouveaux cantons qui
tienne mieux compte de la répartition de
la population assiste le texte officiel
et dès cette première journée de
campagne il faut s'atteler à la tâche du
collage d'affichés sur les panneaux pour
certains comme le candidat alexandre
boucher dans le
ça manque un peu d'expérience à beaucoup
de pays sûrs et de traces de colle pour
sa première affiche collée les plus
anciens eux maîtrise visiblement
l'exercice le maire de dijon à l'ami
oppose ainsi brosse en main dans le
quartier des varennes et puis plus
drôles ou plus bizarre encore dans le
canton de dijon iv
les candidats de l'alternative
écologistes annoncent leur réunion
publique de ce soir sur fond d' affiches
oui mes problèmes leurs photos laissent
plus de place aux autres candidats ceux
de la majorité départementale qui n'en
demandait sans doute pas tant la droite
qui laisse apparaître au grand jour ses
divisions dans le conte tant de talent
et avec une vigueur qui peut laisser
pantois le sénateur ump alain houpert
soutient le duo divers droite
l'ami gaucher face au candidat officiel
de la droite il explique dans ce tweet
assassin qu'il faut changer de menu en
référence aux candidats ump gilbert
menut et à l'aide d'une photo peu
flatteuse du maire de talant les
échanges ont été vifs sur le réseau
social ce week-end et ce lundi gilbert
menut menace ce qui porte la division
aujourd'hui en paieront les conséquences
demain et on termine avec une visite
ministérielle à nevers ce soir oui le
candidat prg michel et store je
bénéficie en ce moment même du soutien
de thierry braillard qui est le
secrétaire d'état aux sports une visite
de soutien express prévue sur deux
heures et deux minutes et cette édition
spéciale élections vont s'enchaîner
prochain one de campagne demain merci
eric